okay so it's a it's a great pleasure to
have um have this really distinguished
panel uh I think most of you know
um uh know both Matt and and dorith
they've been on on panels before at the
colloquium uh and
um
um Matt of course is uh is uh is the
math Hastings of um the Friedman
Hastings conjecture and um
and dorit has um you know has worked
extensive extensively on Quantum fault
tolerance and thought deeply about the
quantum PCB theorem we also have uh
Anand natarajan from MIT who's
um
he he is um you know uh I guess he's
worked extensively on these um on these
uh Quantum multi-prover systems with uh
with the with uh you know with this
Paulie braiding test and also there is a
quote on the MIP star equal to re paper
okay so so let's get started with the
panel and maybe I'll come to you Matt
first because
um after all this was a resolution of
your conjecture so uh can you say a
little bit about
um whether this was you know was was
this along the lines of the resolution
you were expecting and
um you know where where do you expect
this to move move next as well as uh as
well as
maybe also if you can comment on how you
think about about the quantum TCP
theorem in physical terms you know as as
a condensed butter Terrace how what's
what's your view of it and what how
significant it would be from from a
physics viewpoint
uh yeah that's um thanks it's it's a lot
of uh things to come at that so I
probably won't hit all of them um I
think this is
this is really amazing it's really great
to see this resolved
um after all these years I remember Mike
and I had written this paper and kind of
like the day before we were about to
post it on the archive one of us said oh
you know computer scientists really like
these uh acronyms like NP and pqp so we
should make up an acronym for this
conjecture so
maybe maybe that helped because before
it was just conjecture one but uh you
know it's it's it's really great that
it's finally resolved and I think
in a sense yeah I mean I think we would
have expected coding Theory would play a
role but it's great that these
spectacular developments kind of it
seems like everything is falling and
coding Theory you know good codes good
efficiently decodable codes I'm not sure
what's left now except for like good
Quantum locally testable codes but uh
really there's been amazing progress
um
just to comment on yeah I mean how I see
it is condensed minor theorists the way
I always tell physicists about the PCP
theorem is to say it's kind of
surprising because if you want to
estimate the partition function at some
non-zero temperature so you want to like
compute the sum over uh all possible
eigenstates of e to the minus beta e for
some
scalar beta some inverse temperature
beta then
PCP theorem actually tells you that this
is hard to do for some classical
hamiltonians
because uh you know um for sufficiently
low temperature because if it's really
hard to decide whether you know this
this sort of like this extensive error
you can make and it's hard to resolve
the energy to that accuracy it also
becomes hard to resolve the partition
function you know at some low
temperature like maybe temperature one
over 100 but some non-zero temperature
it's hard to estimate it
um and for me always then there was a
tension between that because
you say okay maybe it's hard to estimate
the partition function but then we
always also think of these
partition functions using path integrals
and you think oh finite beta means this
is kind of finite slice in imaginary
time so it kind of looks like it should
be a classical problem so for me it's
it's there's a strong tension between
like using path integrals you think oh
really this is a classical problem
there's only a finite time range but
then
you know here's this highly entangled
hamiltonian that says it's wrong I mean
one thing I'm very curious about is like
thermodynamic properties of these
hamiltonians yeah
uh in and out of equilibrium but uh yeah
that's sort of
so
so you know if if someone were to
speculate you know let's say we created
such a hamiltonian and it was actually
you know uh PCP hamiltonian and it was
it was something you could actually
Implement then would this would would
you know just just putting a speculative
hat on would this would this give you a
new phase of matter what what would this
correspond to physically yeah yeah I
mean this is sort of what I wonder I
mean so suppose we took like a classical
hamiltonian that came from the classical
PCP theorem so it must be very hard to
equilibrate that at low temperature it
must be in fact there's there's really
no easy way to equilibrate it at low
temperature so here I mean maybe there's
some even stronger barrier like maybe
you can't equilibrate it even given some
kind of local information you know I
don't I don't quite know what it would
mean but I
it's suggestive you know I don't I don't
know what it would mean
um
but uh but um
uh what the properties would be but uh
yeah I mean that's I think I think I
heard this talk before and I assuming I
asked about thermodynamics is a member
of the audience but yeah I'm really
curious about it because of this
relationship
thermodynamic properties
right you know since I I think that was
at Santa Barbara right um
um
it's it's sort of strange because it
doesn't behave
probably like the quantum memory
ideas we traditionally think about it uh
right because there are these clusters
these Phantom clusters that exist like
totally you can be low energy and be
kind of very far from the code you know
you can lose all in from all the logical
information can be gone but still the
state is entangled so somehow it it's
saying something
I I I'm I'm Bamboozled by this idea also
you know um
can I also ask like a have a speculative
question to the speaker and this might
be too much asking about my own work but
uh just curious
um so Mike and I uh Mike Friedman and I
had a paper a couple years ago where we
considered
you know a lot of
Quantum codes can be thought of as
originating from some manifold like the
Torah code you take a Taurus and you put
cells on it and um so then you might ask
in the reverse if we're given a code can
we turn it into a manifold with some
cells on it where if the code is ldpc
then these cells correspond to some
well-behaved geometry on the manifold
something not too singular and we
figured out how to do this
um there's some technical condition on
the code needed but as far as I know all
these codes that you consider will obey
that technical condition
um and so there's some
the lowest Dimension we know how to make
it work is 11. so there's some 11
dimensional manifold and there's some
nice cellulation on it that's not too
bizarre such that
you know you identify certain cells with
qubits and certain other ones with Z
checks and X checks and then out pops
this code which is a good Quantum Code
obeying nlts and uh you know
this becomes a new source of examples
for people in geometry and topology and
I'm curious you know
well the fact that the code might be
nlts does this imply anything any
interesting properties of a manifold
where it comes from I don't expect any
like concrete answer but I'm just kind
of
raising it
yeah
uh I'm I'm not sure I mean I I don't
even know how how would one calculate
the genus of this object or something
even these trivial properties uh uh I'm
probably the wrong person to ask for
this maybe um Gail Seymour or you know
any of the mathematicians who really
worked on these codes would access if if
they're here in the audience uh
your perspective would be I I should I
should say that uh chinma and I were
chatting about this just just before you
know earlier this uh uh earlier today
and um and um
um uh Matthew snuck in the question
before you know we were we were thinking
of asking you about the geometry and
topology and so on and so so you beat us
to the punch and okay well then if
you've been asking about there is one
funny question that arises from geometry
anthropology which according dearest
would never want to ask which is that
really this gives not a single manifold
but each code becomes a different
manifold and
um since the codes have encoded logical
qubits this corresponds to some homology
of the manifolds and since these are
good codes as you go through this family
of increasing size codes you're actually
talking about a family of definitely
different manifolds because their
homology is changing and so
someone working in geometry and topology
might be interested rather in is there a
single manifold with a family of metrics
on it and so that asks that then raises
the question can you come up with a code
that has these same properties of having
linear distance or nlts but that has
only one encoded qubit that you
explicitly don't want to be good that
has you know just a very small number of
encoded qubits but retains all the other
properties
um great so you know so
um
student sunny and I uh explored this two
weeks ago and we you know unfortunately
had to post the incorrect proof and then
retract it from the archive we thought
we had a one qubit construction using
classical LPC but there was a fatal
error that basically chalks up to
math over finite fields and reels are
different but yeah so we so I don't know
and I tried taking out the rate
component of this proof and I haven't
been successful so
yeah I'd be very curious
sorry Anna oh I think as we came at it
from like a totally different like we
were we were just interested in whether
the nlts property implies to generacy
of of the of the ground space whether
you could find it and it's just a
rephrasing of the question right
hamiltonian with a non-degenerate ground
space that that's still nlts
um and that seems to be non-trivial
or you didn't have any idea of like the
the manifold sort of
yeah
I see great um so
um actually turning a little bit
um so so uh maybe dorit um you you've
thought a lot about these different
formulations of the quantum PCP theorem
and um also uh also about
various approaches to you know to
classical PCP and whether they're
generalized like some checks and their
nose proof and so on so do you have any
any comments or about that or anything
else about uh
uh I just wanted to say first of all
it's a it's a it's beautiful and really
exciting to see uh this uh this
development
um it's it's basically towards the
quantum PCB it's basically you know just
the uh the first step in the sense that
um so really in order to to actually uh
you mean there's a natural uh there's a
natural Next Step which is to show that
um there are hamiltonians whose ground
States cannot be described uh by a
polynomial
classical description uh not even just
the low energy ground state the low
energy states but even the ground States
um and those would be
hamiltonians which whose ground States
cannot be reached by polynomial
size Quantum circuits meaning that
they're actually not
generatable
um in physics
um we shouldn't think of them as as
states that can be generated in physics
uh May the extended churches and so
um and so thinking about
so okay this is sort of one step one
would have to show that such
hamiltonians exist in order to
uh you know this is this is implied by
the quantum PCP conjecture that
testamentonians exist if we assume that
qma is is not equal to uh to qcma
um right so so so that we would need to
have ground states which require super
polynomial size Quantum circuits to
generate
um so so sorry dorit uh we you know what
happens if you say well let's let's
pretend we are in the world we're we're
qma equal to qcma and then can we show a
Quantum PCP would can you not think
about so what have what happens there in
that in that word
so you're asking about the uh a Quantum
PCP for qcma
yeah so let's let's pretend that let's
pretend that in actual fact qma equal to
qcma right so we we believe not but
let's let's pretend it is so now
um you know could could one could one
imagine a Quantum ECP theorem there or
uh and then
[Music]
um
yeah that that's something that I don't
know exactly how to formulate the
quantum PCP there right you want you
want a state which is which has a
possible easy description but which is
hard to
um
um to to verify using uh using classical
uh easy classical computation but you
need a quantum computer to verify
um
I don't know I can turn the question to
you
sorry is it possible that there is some
intermediate complexity classes that
might be easier before proving that
qpcp is qma is it possible that like
if you could prove that qpcp can resolve
the one clean qubit class for example
which is kind of a natural guess because
it seems like it involves like noisy
things you know could some class like
that be easier to address like dqc1 or
qcma to prove that
front of PCP has at least some limited
power
um
you know I think that's even a nice
concrete question so dur Reid has this
very nice paper with Alex Grillo about
stoclastic hamiltonians
um and that says if you have a
stochastic hamiltonian and you apply a
reduction
and the reduction maintains
stochasticity then you're not going to
get this Quantum PCP it's going to
induce it uh
do randomization
um but if the reduction leaves the
stoclastic world
sort of like in this one qubit sense
then you know you might be able to prove
an MA or other lower bounds also
[Music]
so she may have you have you tried to
think about this uh not the stochastic
thing because this we've talked about
um but about the the lower bounds you
know for basically extending the nlts
injector and now theorem
um to to larger complexity
um I have tried and failed to adjust it
to a very simple
additional class
which is that you get to
um
apply a constant you get to apply a
stabilizer circuit
then a constant depth circuit so this is
another class of classically verified
proofs where you get to do a stabilizer
circuit and then a constant up circuit
on top of it
um so you know the stabilizer circuits
are these very special
um form of classical simulatable Quantum
operations
but I tried messing around with that so
that would give you a lot of depth
um very quickly because you can do a lot
in stabilizer circuits like construct
cat States or all sorts of things
which would break all these
it breaks the argument in our in our
result right open but yeah I I
hoping to work on that more in the
coming days
do you have a candidate hamiltonian
actually because you can't use a code
hamiltonian for this right because the
stabilizer circuit would just
always
right this is sort of it's completely
it's out it's a new direct it needs a
completely new approach to show
um
super linear right or
that kind of a lower band
in fact I don't have examples to start
from probably the best place to start
from that would have to be from some
complexity theoretic conjecture to say
here's a conjecture who knows if it's
true but if it's true it induces this
type of hamiltonian and then that
hamiltonian has this sort of complexity
um and that could be something that's
simple as like qcma not equal to qma you
know as a conjecture or it could be
something a little bit more complicated
um
but that would be my starting point for
such a student
um
sorry uh Chennai then and we were
talking earlier you mentioned something
about
um
you know what what your um
um what your proof has to say about
uh about
you know low depth algorithms like qaoa
so do you want to say a little bit about
that
yeah
um
so
so my naive understanding of qaoa is
that you know you variationally improve
a low depth circuit you keep running a
little bit of circuit use classic
machine learning to update the
parameters you keep getting better in
hopes of finding a ground state for some
hamiltonian
um
right but what we've done here is we've
said okay well you can update the
parameters all you like
if as long as your depth isn't good
enough you know you're never going to
come close to these stabilizer
hamiltonians so ironically qaoa cannot
generate solutions to codes
that's a sort of a result of this
that QA cannot generate the solutions to
these kind of quantum codes even
approximately
um and it's saying that the low depth
approximation the qio is looking for is
sort of
it's not even approximable to sort of
the
stabilizer or coding framework that we
think of there these are like apples and
oranges you know they're two completely
different Notions of classical
approximations to Quantum systems which
is really fun right that we have two
very antithetical ideas and the the
conjecture I just stated about applying
that stabilizer circuit and then I find
constant deficit well let's put these
families together we need to lower
bounds simultaneously to the two things
um
so
okay
um
you know
that's Yeah my two cents on that you
know
um sorry um one uh Anand coming coming
back to you so so you you've uh thought
about the games version of the on the
PCP can you see a little bit about that
and
where where what the status of it is and
you know how it uh how it might relate
to the actual you know quote the PCB
conjecture
sure
um so the status of that is we besides
that it's it's it's open I think it's
kind of a different problem so let me
say what's known about it so that's the
claim that um
the games PCP is that it's qma hard to
approximate the uh value of a non-local
game up to a constant Factor so to
decide so it's like one or a half say
um and so right now we have this uh very
sort of uh strange situation where we
know that this problem is undecidable
um but we can't say that it's qma hard
because we don't have a like a polling
time reduction from the local
hamiltonian problem to this problem
um so uh it's um
we do have a um we do have hardness
results that are sort of like much less
nice than qma hard like like
non-deterministic
okay it's like policy polynomial time
I'm not quite sure I'm saying this right
but essentially the the main technical
difficulty there is that um there's this
tool that's used in building um nominal
games that encode computationally hard
problems which is the the low degree
test and the best known analyzes that
that are just quantitatively not strong
enough and uh I think a bunch of people
have thought about ways to improve that
um and or like Alternatives and we
haven't really succeeded so that seems
to be kind of a barrier to getting
stronger hardness approximation results
for games but I feel like the spirit of
the two questions is quite different
because
um so they're both called pcps because
they're about
trying to approximate the satisfiability
of some sort of quantum constraint
satisfaction problem but because these
are equivalent classically oh yeah so
they are equivalent classically
um so classically why are they
equivalent well there's there's sort of
two Notions of locality that are turned
out to be classically equivalent so
there's one notion which is in an
interactive game or protocol
um each party only operates locally on
the information that it has access to
like it doesn't know anything about the
messages that were sent to the other
parties and then there's a notion of
locality in a hamiltonian or CSP which
is at each constraint only operates on a
small number of variables and
classically there's this very simple
idea just like the idea of taking a
transcript of an interaction that that
converts one notion into the other well
one way you you can write down a
transcript and the way you can use this
thing called the Clause variable game so
they're equivalent but in the quantum
setting that this just totally fails
like there's no there's no analog that
we know of to that so um the tools also
that we use like show hardness for games
seem in some ways kind of different so
that's my
my feeling I think it would be a very
interesting
like maybe at a higher level is like the
the lot of the like games results are
inspired by the algebraic proof of the
of the classical PCP theorem um which
used ideas from algebra and also coding
Theory
um and in the quantum side uh for for
hamiltonians I don't know they're like
people have thought much about whether
like the algebraic parts of this
Construction in particular could be
useful like the specifically like the
fact that like the read molar codes like
crucial to the classical PCP because is
there some way that it can be used for
Quantum hamiltonian PCP uh but I have no
idea
great um
see there there's somebody in the
audience who's been waiting to talk for
a while let me uh fight so uh so let's
see if uh do you have something you
would like to say hi yeah I wanted to
jump in about the question about pcps
for qcma
uh so I've been thinking about that
actually for a while uh
Maybe
so I think like one can State such a
conjecture
in terms of the
uh Gap amplification of frustration free
like XZ hamiltonians
and actually like uh
it would be
like the rate was remarking also like
it's uh like the the the fact that the
ground stays for such problem
[Music]
are efficiently preparable somehow that
makes it like more like physically like
plausible or friendly uh
so yeah I don't know like how if other
people thought about like this direction
but the fact that QC may like is equal
to qcma was perfect completeness somehow
like also opens the door to like this
uh sort of Direction in this direction
the PCP theorem would
uh like look like a classical string
that somehow you pre-process
and then a quantumly like access a
certain number of qubits in the
pre-processed
string
um
maybe while
tourists think about data Civic also had
a question maybe if you want to do you
want to jump into
sure
um can you hear me
yeah yeah great uh so great talk to me
thank you I just want to quickly ask
Anand what what do you mean by you said
the the games version of quantum PCP is
open uh how does that relate to your
paper with Thomas
um Tama a lot of great testing for
Quantum States and a Quantum entangled
games PCP yeah so what am I missing here
ah so this paper
um this paper used uh this earlier
result of of Tama that the the quantum
sun is the low degree test
um and that paper was found to have a
bug later so the like it claimed some
like sort of constant soundness but the
best you can now get is is is like I
don't know one of her poly log or
something and that's not good enough to
get the the PCP statement oh I see okay
okay so I was aware
right yeah
sorry what does that mean quasi-pcp here
well exactly what Nana said the Gap is
one over probably logging oh sorry sorry
I missed that part sorry yeah thank you
I think also there's like we we need to
check it very carefully all right um we
should uh even
like it that paper is a lot of technical
machinery and it's possible that you
know I I tried looking at it once I was
you know I didn't find any bug but past
the quasi-pcp idea but it's possible oh
yeah
yeah sorry and then go ahead go ahead
no I wanted to say something about the
QC bank so go ahead uh it's slightly off
oh I just wanted to say yeah it's true
that we haven't really
um Revisited that result in a while so
um I haven't like actually worked out
you know
you know written up formally that it's
like you get a class in PCP so
yeah so I just wanted to say one thing
about the qcma
um the the question about the the qpcp
for for qcma which I find a bit sort of
unnatural the question because because
really
um I mean one of the motivations for or
one of the reasons why Quantum PCP is
such an interesting conjecture
um is because it asks questions about
the nature of ground States and of local
hamiltonians and
and the qpcp version of that
I don't know exactly what that means but
but whatever that version is it's no
longer talking about ground states of
local hamiltonians and entanglement it's
talking about verification processes
which is of course extremely interesting
but it's it's sort of taking the
question to a different direction
[Music]
um
so I find it a bit
I don't know less less healing
um this question though it may be very
interesting to you know as a step as a
technical step
so you're referring to the games version
the read no I was referring to the to
the hamiltonian to the
um
not to the games version but you could
you could think of a qcma PCP version
with a gap
um but where the ground states have have
classical descriptions
um official classical descriptions and
then and then the question becomes a
question of of hardness of a
verification in the classical world
compared to to bqp verification sorry so
there it's a if if we had if he were
looking at a games sorry uh you know uh
a PCP term for for qcma
wouldn't that still have the same same
thing about the Gibb State and you know
hardness of of estimating partition
function and so on won't
hold so so when when you say you find it
less well motivated what do you mean
then there well I just mean that that
you're basically
somewhat less motivated not completely
but you're basically restricting
yourself to local momentonians whose
ground states have classes that's PCB
have official classical descriptions
um hang on I might be confused about so
I probably I probably am confused about
something here but suppose someone
tomorrow proved a theorem that said
every local hamiltonian
because
a low energy state that can be created
by starting with a product States and
acting by a polynomial depth
circuit
um local Gates but the circuit might
have polynomial depth rather than
constant depths then qcma equals human
yeah well well no no it's not that every
like every state of
doesn't that not qcm equals qma not
every every like it's ground state but
every state of less than you know energy
0.01 fraction wouldn't that would that
would that wouldn't that just imply that
Quantum PCP is at most qcma but still
might be more than anything that's right
yes
yeah exactly I am actually a believer in
that regime that's my best guess
yeah okay
um
yeah in fact it might actually be even
okay I may take it back that it's less
appealing it might actually be more
appealing
the point of view
at least that talks about hamiltonians
whose ground states are in this world
absolutely I I think it's a very nice
question it's uh it's um okay very nice
Direction I agree
I guess there's also a little bit of a
pitfall that one has to avoid which is
that you know there was a lot of work
classically to think about what is a PCP
for Merlin Arthur mean for just with
Randomness it's very hard to describe
what that is because
in in some sense
uh the randomness is necessary in
verifying the proof and you need a lot
of it right if you need a very little
amount of Randomness to verify the proof
then um
it uh just becomes NP the PCP says that
you can verify proofs with just like log
n Bits of Randomness right but Merlin
Arthur says you actually need n Bits of
randomness
to do something so there's sort of this
disconnect
there and then qcma has a similar flavor
but what happens with qma that's so
beautiful is that you directly you have
Quantum access to this state you just
measure it right away right there's no
pre-processing no you don't have to take
the circuit description build a state
then measure the state
it's just you just hit the ground
running same as you do an end Peak and
that that that's that small subtlety
maybe it's insignificant but it's
certainly um a complexity and any proof
that one might
hope to write down
so just to follow up on that so in terms
of a Quantum in terms of PCP for ma like
let's forget the stochasticity for a
second like you might wonder if quantum
might help you because like why okay why
is there not obviously a PCP for ma is
that there's a different CSP that you're
checking for every Merlin uh for every
Arthur uh
for every set of random bits right
um yeah
then but you might imagine that maybe
like you get a proof that's a super
position over like assignments to all
the things that you might possibly check
um and then somehow you check that it's
like actually a truly superposition and
then you run your classical PCP verifier
on each branch like have you explored
any idea of this form like
because that that would be interesting
and you'd say that there's a Quantum
state that you can read a few qubits up
and see the truth
statement
s
I haven't thought about this idea at all
either so it's just uh
yeah suggestion yeah
so far NP lower Bound for Quantum pcps
is is right is known right that's uh
just from password piece to be so I
guess what we're saying is what are all
the different bars like what is the ma
lower bound look like what does qcma law
around look like okay can you get to the
top rung of cumulative
yeah great
well this was a lot of fun
um it was both a panel and a
brainstorming session we should do this
more often
uh so so thanks a lot Chennai for a
great talk and thank you all for the for
the panel and
uh all the questions so oh before we end
maybe I should say one thing I forgot to
say in the topic which is that
um you know one might say okay if you
prove this Quantum you know Quantum
codes wow they're so useful in improving
nlts what about Quantum LTC like say
someone comes up with Quantum ltc's
tomorrow the quantum PCB conjecture
doesn't just like appear out of thin air
hey you know no one has written that oh
a proof that Quantum LTC implies Quantum
PCP and this because actually codes are
both a boon and a curse
um and their their Boon in the in
precisely the talk that I gave that you
know they proved these robustness
guarantees they're cursed though in that
they have to involve this local and
distinguishability
so and simultaneously being local
indistinguishability and in coding
computation seems
hard because local indistinguishably
means there's no information encoded in
small regions so it's actually not
entirely obvious how codes
play a role in Quantum pcps they played
a really big rodent
all known constructions of classical
pcps
but it's unclear I think that's a
maybe if Dory has anything to say about
that that would be a good thing to end
on well I think you're right that I mean
even classically we don't have
this connection right so
so yeah so I think I think what you said
was uh there was clear-cut
okay
I just want to say that given given the
this 10 years or so of of research on a
PCP or much more I don't know
um I'm not even sure if the if the if
the odds you know if if we would have
now uh had a a vote on on Believers of
quantum PCP versus non-believers if uh
if the numbers now were larger than than
10 years ago
um I think it's not
not clear I don't know I remember math
uh we had a hike uh a long long time ago
when we had a
discussion about this and I don't know
what you think now well yeah I remember
um
I think uh this this was in Santa Fe in
2007 or something and I remember mostly
as a joke I think scrolling in the sand
that's content PCP was NP to the dqc one
and uh that was a joke but I'll raise it
to the status of the conjecture
something intermediate
yeah how does one cite a beach sand
writing in the newspaper
you know if you if you want people to
work on it you have to come up with a
four-letter acronym for it
okay well
we'll come up with one
but I believe it's intermediate yeah I
don't know what to orient or anyone
else's beliefs what if we took a vote
I'll vote for intermediates
um
I'm not willing to because you have to
vote something you're more than empty
well if I'm if I have to vote if I
really enforced to vote I would I would
actually say that it's not uh that it's
not
but I hope I hope it's not recorded by
now
not qma but more than NP or
probably more than yeah I don't know
well there was a very nice nice thought
before that it might be qcma
great
well on that note maybe uh thank you
everybody and thanks Jimmy again for the
talk
see you all next week
bye